[Musique]
quel dirigeant pour venir voir c'est
quoi comme secrets
oh non il n'y a pas de secret c'est pas
ce que si le jeune épouse il me fait de
bonne cuisine et qui brosse quoi nous a
donné envie de venir mais ça va parce
que j'étais sur mon chantier naval et
que ça fait faillite
juste après la guerre sa chute et après
la guerre donc l'homme et islam avait
comme intérêt c'est un peu mon enfin bon
[Musique]
moi je fasse quelque chose
les des bons moments comme les gens sont
gentils bon jour elle n'a pas un cadeau
c'est exceptionnel mais il avait
toujours des cathos donc john sur
connaissance il s'était terminée celle
des problèmes anciens
je préfère avoir un enfant à venir et je
suis personne que je parle et qu'on a à
l'aise comme les camions elle repère
c'est vrai rien de très très humain moi
j'appelle papilles à dans la famille
parce qu'on allait durer longtemps je
vais dire on s'est souvent médecins et
et ma famille mon père qui l'a pas vu et
j'ai beaucoup d'attachement au g10 et
donne un temps de dieu n'est pas de
simples par an pas plus que ta part
à 40 ans il vous voit vous continuez
toujours avec nous tous si lui manque
dit si ça y est nous en 2007 et même pas
mal changé rien